why are there so many bones in breath of
the wild some of them spring to life at
night and others lie there prompting
Zelda fans to make theory after theory
as to what they used to be when they
were living and these fossils are all
over the place like the giant Leviathan
bones the protruding ribs and this giant
skull bone of what appears to be some
sort of dragon head hmm
am I missing something oh yeah and the
skulls that make up becau in camps
that's right the giant humanoid looking
skulls that problems Marlins and
lizalfos loved to camp in may just be
the most mysteriously mystifying mystery
bones of them all and they've been right
under our noses this whole time I mean
if these skulls were really once living
beings walking around Hyrule can you
imagine how big they were before they
died but I'm jumping ahead of myself we
have to answer some questions first
before speculating about anything
regarding their past living cells such
as are they even bones at all or just
carved out rock without further ado
allow me to humbly present the mystery
of the ancient Giants to begin let's
focus on the question I brought up just
a few seconds ago are the mysterious
giant skulls that becau blends and the
like used for encampments actually made
of bone or are they just carved out rock
looking at the texture of the skulls it
could actually go either way this could
be what the surface texture looks like
of a really weathered bone or it could
be really weathered rock and with the
skulls sitting on top of the ground it's
difficult to tell if they complete
beneath the surface however when I
compared the two textures to each other
directly
I noticed the skull is slightly lighter
than the rocks and harsh these are two
pictures I took from the same area at
the same time of day one of a giant
skull and one of a nearby exposed wall
of rock the sunlight is hitting both
surfaces at a similar angle
giving us an accurate comparison of
color as you can see the developers of
breath of the wild distinctly decided to
give the skulls a slightly wider texture
than the slightly more dark bluish rock
wall since we can see that they actually
have different textures that means that
they are deliberately well different
you know what else is white bones but
banded I hear you asking what about the
other bones that we can see in breath of
the wild they have more of a yellowish
color doesn't this mean the skulls are
not organic bones after all well not
necessarily you see bones always start
off white when they first exit the body
the only time you see a bone that is not
pure white in color is when it's been
exposed to some degree of the natural
process of weathering for a long period
of time that's when it can become that
off why yellowish brown color we see in
breath of the wild so the skulls not
being the same color as some of the
other bones like the protruding ribs
doesn't necessarily mean they're not
bones at all honestly it just means that
they're fresher in the area full of
quicksand known as the bottomless swamp
that humongous monstrous skull mentioned
earlier sits right smack in the middle
of the marsh and wouldn't you know what
the texture of the monstrous skull is
very similar to the skulls that the
bakov ones use for camps but it gets
better when I was comparing these
textures and venturing around the area
of the swamp I discovered something else
that was rather interesting about
halfway down this hill there are three
camp skulls on top of each other more
buried in the dirt than any other skulls
I've seen now let me ask you this if
this was all just carved out Rock what
in the world would be the purpose of
taking the time to craft three skulls
crammed one on top of the other
including the bottom ones entrance being
straight up inaccessible through the
regular opening even for bakov ones that
seems a little well dumb but really the
nail in the coffin lies to the northeast
in Death Mountain you see all that red
stuff yeah that's lava you see those
skulls sitting in the lava since the
melting point of human bone is upwards
of 1,600 degrees Celsius and lava burns
at a temperature between 700 and 1,200
degrees Celsius that could definitely be
bone if buck oblems built that they'd
have to be able to survive in a pool of
lava so let's test that theory
so yeah no boo Collins did not make
those skulls out there I mean I guess
the lava dwelling lizalfos could have
made them but look what is the point of
making this what they needed a little
shade oh and what about this one way
over here and this other cracked one are
these rock carvings are broken skulls I
say all of this to conclude that given
the textures the similarity with another
monstrous skull and sporadic placement
that makes no logical sense for a camp
and they're sometimes you know shattered
statuses I believe the giant skulls are
in fact organic bones from what were
once giant living beings this brings us
to the next logical question what the
heck were they anyway I mean the Legend
of Zelda has giants but not many are
that big looking within the world of
breath of the wild itself the biggest
and baddest Giants of the land would be
the hen X's but these skulls are like
half as big as a hen ik TSA's entire
body also there's a glaring problem
there with Hynix as being you know
cyclopses with one eye and these skulls
having you know 2i holes searching
through all of the zelda franchises
species and characters I was only able
to find a couple different possibilities
as to who these skulls used to be the
first of which would be the four Giants
from Majora's Mask but that's crazy
right no one would believe that I'm not
kidding guys no one would believe that
not even me there were only four of them
they were deities they were from a land
that we don't even know if it exists or
at the very best is a parallel reality
to our own so yeah it's not the four
Giants I don't even know why I brought
them up but anyway the other possibility
is also pretty crazy but you ready for
this because things are about to get
wild
the only other humanoid figure with two
eyes and a nose and a mouth and a skull
that's that big would be big or on you
remember the giant goron who lived at
the top of Death Mountain in ocarina of
time the one who gave you the big goron
sword after that long and weighing
trading quest well it is actually
confirmed that that dude has a family as
in there's more than one of him you
remember his brother medgar
the one who's also a giant just not
quite as big but that's probably because
he's not full-grown
we know that gowron's don't just
continually grow themselves they do stop
growing once they reach maturity as we
see from the old and pretty tiny
gowron's pictured in Twilight Princess
that means big Goran and his brother
meta Goran or from a race of well giant
gowron's a race that has existed for a
long long time in fact an ancestor big
goron makes an appearance in the game
the Minish Cap and we know this is an
ancestor not the same big Gorn from
ocarina of time but an older one because
the one from the Minish Cap is said to
be bigger than mountains but the one in
ocarina of time is just not that big
we even see big gorons line continuing
in front of our very eyes in Phantom
Hourglass because in that game he has a
son named GaN goron I'm saying all of
this to conclude that you know with how
family trees work the amount of
descendants that an individual has grows
exponentially depending on how much time
has passed you know two people have two
children they each have two children
those children have two children and on
and on and on you go until you have no a
million children or something like that
applying this to big gowron's race we
should be able to see quite a few big
gorons around the world since it's been
at least more than ten thousand years
since the last zelda game but where are
they well with big gorons race being the
only living beings in zelda lore that
fit the size and skull description and
knowing that his line did continue
onward
I think these skulls can answer that
question what if we do see them but not
in their living forms and they either
died off long long ago due to some
unknown circumstances or since these
skulls are still white and spread all
over Hyrule died relatively recently due
to the events of the battle 100 years
ago it's very possible that since
they're you know giants they were kind
of Hyrule super soldiers in the fight
against Ganon's monsters but ultimately
they were killed in the struggle by
Ganon's overwhelming forces as was
everybody and their decomposed skulls
made into enemy and
Hammond's as a statement of their
victory over the towering goron Warriors
the fact that none of them exist in a
graveyard but rather are literally just
spread around Hyrule and some even piled
on top of each other seems to suggest
that the cause and circumstances
surrounding their deaths were both
unanticipated and happened all around
the same time both of those reasons
point to what happens in warfare but
this is all just pure speculation
the final possibility is of course that
they're just some unknown race of giants
that simply died long ago around the
same time all around Hyrule I mean the
giant monster skull is from an unknown
origin so why shouldn't these skulls be
the same way so given the possibilities
what do you think is it big gowron's
race or another unknown race of giants
let me know in a comment below hey guys
thanks so much for watching please be
sure to leave me a like if you enjoyed
this crazy theory and subscribe with
that Bell icon so you don't miss out on
all the Nintendo goodness happening
right here on mass Nintendo bandage huge
thanks to my amazing patrons as always
you all continue to make my day every
day if you're interested in making my
day and getting your name featured up
here at the end of all of my Theory
videos and helping to support the
channel feel free to follow the link in
the description below also down there
are links to my social media pages so
please stop on by and say hi to me
that's all I've got for you in this one
so check out another video this is masks
antenna bandits signing out stay safe
wash your hands and have a good one
[Music]